botaram é obrigado eu vou tentar ficar
em primeiro não tem direito no país
depois vocês já devem estar todos
cansados tanque é uma forma muito tímida
mesmo em dornelas tem 39 anos e tem uma
filha que está aqui é presente militar
no ecrã seu direito ao crédito em uma
agência de marketing digital que amanda
itanhi projetada nele e vai ficar
falando de ontem sobre o projeto e sobre
a capacidade nós temos que mudar muito
é como é que isto começou a se
concentrar muito inspirado educado e e
um sinal nem sempre uma série de
projetos e uma série de pequenos países
ao longo da vida em nosso dia a dia e
projetos comuns na praça grátis
o mais humor favor sempre foram projetos
que encaram e conheceram comigo esse
projeto é dos improveverywhere e euros
basicamente 011 público na rua e ver
quais são as tuas para que dissessem
coisas bonitas e produzir que este
projeto em lisboa e para mim este coisas
de mensagens de e jets e em prol dos
outros sempre foi uma coisa que me
impressionou e conclui com um vôo é
pensar nisso e um dia da mpb como
projeto desculpa com projéteis tinham
que usar franco tem uma série teto e eu
já conhecia alguns projetos viu como por
exemplo um projeto que está em que uma
música para cantar nos com temos medo e
e então zé franco recebeu um e-mail de
uma senhora que andava muito triste e
basicamente de sto
o lazer é só uma fase do projeto que era
de som que este projecto está a falar
se fizer o tryp favor fazer uma música
para quando sua cento sobre o real
número de que duas se calmamente um
profissional de mil desta expressão de
um abraço ao vivo e uma calça uma tensão
que cercou chega à sua volta em suas
camas está tudo bem então eu recebeu
este mal em consulta a trabalhar na
letra música e na música e me perguntou
várias vezes colocava sentir como é que
não sentia e então conseguiu envolver a
combinar deu em torno da ajuda que esta
senhora que se sentia triste que sente
deprimida
e então eu criei esta música em que a
primeira parte fala como é que ela cento
e depois escolheu participar tem que
entrar comunidade que que gerir que na
volta dele é e que o seu trabalho deu em
que explica que vai ficar tudo bem eu
não sei se a música vai ficar no
supersimples cheiro é horrível
eu penso que o resultado todas as fotos
premiadas lentos o homem agora anda
acontecendo
ok
resolvi falar que eu ouvi falar
depois todas as escolas todos os chefes
aos milhares
i
e na minha opinião este noite com um
toque foi exatamente isto é ter uma
pessoa aja vai ficar em torno da cidade
de central e em conseguir juntar venise
dinamizar todo né e cancerígeno vai
ajudar essa pessoa marca escola e isso
quando vier a resposta dela em casa de
josé esta é uma das coisas mais bonitas
que alguém já fez por mim
não consigo agradecer o suficiente nem
sei como se tem estatura na roda e ter
um estranho feliz por mim com a
distância participaram de sessões
moradora de uma maneira incrível então
tão obrigado
e quando eu vi esse projeto quando é com
esse projeto e comecei a pensar nisto
como realmente acho muito importante ea
extraordinária convocada para discutir
porém sem qualquer contrapartida ajudar
outra pessoa ainda conseguiu fazer com
que outras pessoas ajudem a si mesmo tô
sem ninguém saber quem era este celular
a sós evento ela sentia triste e
deprimida e então eu tive meio ainda nem
era tão simples como dar um fazer alguém
feliz na vida das pessoas fazer a
observação ganhos cada casa dela nem
fazia ideia que continua
encontrei um gueto officer um café ou o
que fosse e criar um projeto que tem
este nome é estranhíssimo que era
difícil dizer ea definição de imprimir
mas que é basicamente às 11 30 em
colocar a menina era pequeno espaço
pequenas ações e que objetos que não
fazem realmente mudar o mundo e é ver o
filme coloca um dos tais filmes em campo
move sensibilização mineral na parte em
que ela disse que se conseguir
impressionar uma pessoa específica
a gente fica então vai passar a fazer
isso com todas as pessoas que vivem à
volta dela e um da ure a vida das
pessoas que vivem à volta dela ninguém
então passei a chamar o projeto não
estranhe o projeto melo e que não é mais
do que nas ações que tenham como
objetivo um ladrão nações de em salas
sem qualquer contrapartida
faça uma criança sorrir ao centro
espanhol impressionados com a goleada e
algumas bastante assim como o dia a dia
de uma pessoa e que essa pessoa chega em
casa com o estoril por contágio
então quando saí é claro autocolantes de
espalhar mensagens como esta
estudo no circo no espaço onde eu vivia
onde eu trabalhava tanto no restaurante
um dia e as pessoas a 40 casas bandeiras
com o nome que não é mas é bom então no
meu carro trabalho e deixava as cartas
convite quando vi no meu carro chefe em
staccato escondido num sítio não faz
ideia de os encontrar um que dizia eu
quero meu e provavelmente comprou a satã
comprar um pouco pois um casal vivendo
pois não negociará um bom carro não é
muito mas também nunca disse pinto foi
um janeiro com a loja cheia de muitos o
tips na mala acaba de inventar e tiveram
uma filha que fez nesse caso nem se vai
entrar de primeira viagem carro
espero que gostem fácil muitas boas
viagens com escolas nele o nome
simpático mamede em organizar e acima de
tudo de visitas em depoimento que o
fazia era isto passava num sítio melhor
e deixava deixar um hotel clinton vai
deixar um carro ou pegar com que a feira
virtual ganha você como eu trabalhava na
rua castilho é emel que era um alvo
muito fácil e então substituir jonas
todas deltur em vez do amarelo do
jornaleiro e comecei a deixar carlos aos
66 montavam car todos os dias é os meus
dentes e das pessoas mais adiantadas a
face da terra portanto eu achei que era
simpático e eu venho trabalhando e me
formar e informar o carro não tinha para
quem deus tenham consultado e começou um
custo ambiental de dobby por parte das
pessoas e eu resolvi começar a deixar a
casa de um primo tac não tava foi
franquis dias a idéia é deixar cadê o ps
não levo pensando neste ambiente que os
caras viveram quando não fazer ao mundo
como escreve cartas todos os dias é uma
graça e quem acha que a conta disso eu
nunca fui bloqueado aos catalães a nato
e assegurou que havana mesmo mas pra
galera pensar que cheguei alguma branco
e o projeto foi que o time pelo meio dos
amigos que hoje praticam a fazer sushi e
deixou algumas linhas enquanto fizer
esta ação de inscrições em tua e
correções nos mafuz inclui poucos até
malta achou graça
e e resolveu entrevistar um país quanto
o tabaco subiram muitas outras
outras publicações e foi a provisão e
tenta falar tudo gente ficava sempre
implantado no funil cavalcanti então a
gente viver no pará tocantins e é este é
o momento em que deixar de subir após já
não aguentava mais filhos se virou as
costas mesmo fotografarem subiram pode
parecer uma que quem tentou as vidas
sinais opostos pra isto pode chegar ao
ponto em que encontrar um mundo eo que
quer afundar o mundo fala e eu falava do
dodô nome inicial do projeto pequeno
espaço quando muito e aquelas temos de
ver com com os cats do ricardo espera é
que faz o vilão e iam diz que ele deu
para dominar o mundo não é dominar muito
com aquele cenário dominado forma
sustentada ou seja eu disse como é óbvio
não vai dominar muito de uma vez e vai
começar a produzir um tempo tem algo
fácil e isso fez logo sentir ao mesmo
tempo também tem graça tem uma grande
importância por trás que não há maneira
nós conseguimos mudar o mundo todo nos
vinhos da mesma noite não é como maneira
de dominar no mundo todo uma vez mexer
na conta quando chegarem ao faça
conseguirmos cara é dominar o mundo e
ainda 1 mil projetada ele continua
aquecido e conseguiu realmente rua que
este promundo expressam cada um exagero
mas a verdade é que pedro consegue
escrever mensagens do outro de outras
pessoas a fazerem projetar ele quer em
portugal e espanha x portugal of fire
coimbra portuguesa não consigo vestir as
cores que muitos contatos por uma pessoa
que viu a implementar o projeto no
brasil já está implementado no brasil
sempre com o mesmo espírito das pessoas
às vezes inventam a forma como fazem
outras vezes copiam o que eu fiz fazenda
um novo peão e isso argentina com o nome
praia também lhe painel de projeto
a verdade é que o projeto foi crescendo
e sem um candidato que sting e chegou
pronto o estudo a partir da da parte da
comunicação social têm lugar no projeto
que teve localmente um grande impulso ao
projeto com as ferramentas nós temos
nossas cores que vim aqui um crime falar
como facebook twitter youtube e nós
estamos cada vez mais próximos ao mesmo
tempo
temos ferramentas hoje em dia que nos
permitem chave é muita gente fazer nossa
mensagem é muito bons e muito mais longe
do que alguma vez se imaginarmos porque
sequer uns anos atrás dissessem que o
irã já bom dia a 9 mil pessoas ou não um
indivíduo chegava a 30 mil pessoas eu ia
dizer que não completamente looks que
não fazia sentido nenhum
mas a verdade é que isso aconteceu e
relatava que mudar o meu mundo não só
pelo mundo em alcobaça
não é no meu terreno ao classe e neste
momento o projeto enquanto a espanha por
todo lado e como não projetar muito como
fotos go tem 100 mil fãs oeste com
lentes que é um projeto newton sofrido
bullying na escola e que diz a mãe não
queria receber uma mensagem de anos
quando fizesse 11 anos a mãe criou uma
página tem dois milhões de fãs e vai a
todo lado é uma estrela ou indiretas do
banco só mensagens sobre positivas têm
mais um milhão que faz o refúgio que não
tem nada a ver com este projeto que eu
faço é a distribuição de comida e outros
países alimentados por pessoas que
precisam ser conhecidos em uma bicicleta
e portanto o profissional que já sabia
da função do triângulo provavelmente ali
onde vivia e os restaurantes que
frequentava e hoje ele está hospedado
pelo inter ele tem no currículo entre
voluntários que acaba é crucial pois
temos um do mundo hoje em dia muitos fãs
gritava e perseguir os nossos sonhos
andar atrás dos nossos sonhos não darmos
um cigano de consciência que mudar um
pode ser só um barulho muito à nossa
volta só a nossa casa sem acreditar no
que estamos a fazer e eu acho que foi
isso que eu vou projetar militou nos foi
eu acreditar sinceramente tudo que
estava a fazer
não custa nada é uma coisa que o
investimento por exemplo nunca fez
qualquer investimento em publicidade não
tem uma agência de comunicação tratado
nada e com o mínimo de esforço o projeto
realmente difícil porque o acreditar no
projeto e fui atrás do que o que fazia
estava gosto de fazer e praticamente só
somos verdadeiramente feliz quando os
cubanos que o funcionário futura nem
isto está nos assistindo sonharmos
queremos fazer uma viagem à volta do
mundo se queremos ter uma agência onde
vamos todos trabalhar frizzo diz posso
não vamos começar
com mais de 130 pessoas até 50 pessoas
que não vão descansar dois extremos numa
loja de energias não temos como nos
defender bem né
mas conhecemos clean e começamos nosso
real faça
estamos crescendo e isso nós fomos
felizes de poder que fazemos seja
agências e uma loja foram os dois duas
pessoas fluídos uma série infeliz
junta-se uma quarta flynn e assim
conseguimos construir nosso sonho foram
os gostos infeliz ninguém que venha
trabalhar conosco porque se vocês
pensarem no bairro e espancava
se vocês pensarem bem o já mencionado
mais do que o tocantins são mera
tocantins com custam nada fazer com
custo - imprimir e errada que saiu do
meu pequeno em alcobaça e pôs no mundo e
se eu conseguir fazer isso contra o
atlântico mim ferramentas e sem qualquer
investimento
vocês vão conseguir fazer muito mais e é
isto